you what's the thing that you haven't
done in your personal life that you
still want to do and what's the thing in
your professional life that you still
want to do and haven't done
yet I've done my personal life I'm very
happily married great girl lovely
children done finished cooked uh
professionally I don't know you know I I
want to finish that book I wrote half a
novel and I need to finish finish it is
it that made me nicer is it fiction or
is fiction fiction how how will you find
the time to write the second half well I
won't ever and then I'll die unfied
miserable well you were going to do that
probably anyway regardless yeah
yeah